hallo mein name ist zusätzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ihr seht schon ich sitze zusammen
mit marxheim und
wir machen was wir
machen heute wieder eine challenge aber
letztens irgendwann schon mal gemacht
haben was wir letztes gemacht habe
verdiene ich euch hier irgendwo da sind
eingeblendet und zwar haben wir jetzt
mal so gemacht dass ich eine tastatur
gespielt habe und max an der maus jetzt
switch mir das ganze allerdings wir
haben diesmal keine maut hand kennen
aber glaubt uns einfach dass einer von
uns das ding bedient einer die mauer
hier machen extra unseren armen auf
vorrücken damit ihr sehen sind dass wir
nur jeder mit einer hand um hantieren
und wir haben jetzt so gut wie ich für
fast eigene
geht's um bronze gehen als im bild uhr
einpacken erklärt klick bequem bestellt
werden die bobs mal wieder und jetzt
wartet wir brauchen die blöcke okay ich
habe richtig dumme ding gewinnen wollen
wir wie vielleicht 10 24 oder 24.000 24
35 aber auch ja ok indem wir 5
das war richtig eng 2 dann drehten muss
ein bisschen gucken mobil zu vor uns hin
bauen eine folge wären die ersten der
mitte und hätten als erstes gold alter
das war letztmalig auch der fall aber da
konnten wir damit nicht so viel
anstellen nochmal zum bachelor und zu
unserer
dass alles so gut auf die mieter vor
allem im kopfhörer drin ich habe gar
nichts macht hat irgendwie alles ich ein
bisschen mehr hat quasi das doppelte und
ich war nicht aber ich hab so drin ist
ist unbekannt spring mit dem krieg war
okay das ganze leute wollen das ganze
volk das ganze geld das ganze wird dann
wieder zurück zu renault kam das gold
lassen mitnehmen okay wir können jetzt
schon das frühstück wird und hoffen das
leben wartet schildhauer laufe langsam
wachsen die hatten schon mal dass wir
unser gefeiert ich würde fast sagen sind
besser geworden ist besser geworden weil
wir jetzt so umschauen da agieren findet
doppelt
ich dachte wir sind zwei leute ich
behandle hörst du nur eine person
warum alles zweimal das war schluss soll
ich das nur eins drückst um das thema zu
hören
ich habe angst dass vielleicht einer
kommen wir warum glas drehen bogen
wartet im bund wir brauchen bogen für
bogen jetzt könnte es auch eine
rettungsplattform wollen die es
vielleicht ganz nützlich wenn wir die
angst da fallen also spezial altkanzler
ist das wort das ist die jetzt brauchen
wir essen und gehen auf
spitzenspieler oder ihres schießen ab
links links links meine ich mit links
und rechts
bisschen weiter unten bitten wir darum
wie wurde abgeschlossen ist
der fall der sturz war schon okay
scheißegal werden so bereiten wir haben
die besten items
man nächstes schlechteste warum bin ich
schlecht weil ich nicht schlecht bin
kämpfen kämpfen geh mal auf den nächsten
zug immer wir sind höchstens vierter
ok jetzt ordert ein schwert der
landshuter rettungsplattform ja
natürlich ich dachte ich dass ich weg
oder so nein nein die die habacker bis
16,1 schlag schon durchschlagen lustlos
ok
alter sehr gut sehr gut serviert
grad retten so viel holz was mache ich
bin genauso ich hab die maus genommen
aber dies eine schnelle geschwindigkeit
das direkt mal lebens gegangen ist dann
wollte ich den retten nach rechts
sondern aber gut geklappt noch mal glück
perfekt gerannt ich wollte retten vor
und einander geht's unser wehrdienstes
unterwäsche und ist einer unserer
abgebaut oder ich war halt nichts
unterbett nicht ab aber wir sind im kies
dann kriegen wir das unter die heiße
luca flug man was tut er
was okay aber er ist auch unter
verbessere wie sagte unser bett ich hab
gebaut was im gamestar noch eingebaut
oder so das komplett umgestellt ok ab
dem ersten angriff auf angriff so doll
ich kann ok
wollen angreifen ja komplett
local loop
man bisher so dran was fällt dem einen
uns irgendwie anzugreifen
mach schon
kommt auch schon außen rum jetzt hier
gehen hier in schorsch auch nicht nach
ihm ja wir sind drin perfekt perfekt es
wäre schon ein wasserbett guten gegner
auch die 141 was ein blöder ja
[Applaus]
wichtig egal ob dir sagen
egal
wir sind unter den letzten drei lebende
wir haben nur einen getötet lukmon alter
stelle mir vor wie gewinnen das kann
nicht sein mag wir werden das nicht
gewinnen alter wir sind einfach dritter
was also gut reingepasst was wir machen
aber wir haben nur einen wir haben ein
gefühl wir haben jetzt irgendwie umgehen
als anziehen als anziehen wir sind schon
wieder voll gekriegt ok meisten
das verdammt ok-team laut zerstört auf
beiden anna ludwig wir nehmen es noch
ein bisschen gold mit
den über das loch grant kann das gar
nicht kommentieren weil noch nie so gut
springe ich springe ich bringe
hochbahn
red apa was noch ein wert abgebaut wie
kann das sein alter wie gut sind wieder
in dem blau wurde vernichtet ok alter
stelle okay zum teil porta a porta so
kommen wir jetzt in unsere base zu
rückschlag einfach schon mal los wenn
wir in unserer welt sehen weil
vielleicht erwartung steve starter kit
die sind unser bis zum ersten mal
positiv mitbekommt ich wusste gleich
dass es ein item gibt helfer zurück die
base kann ich das einschätzen
er ist runtergefallen ok erst unter
gefallen gerade das hat keine sachen wer
das sagt mir jetzt den teleporter eine
andere base wie eine perle halt da musst
du nur gut zielen das ist das problem
signalisieren die hoch so ja und dann
direkt aus schwert so ja okay wir gehen
rüber ich habe auf fertig
wie knapp alter aber halb so viel wert
wie wir sind jetzt wieder das kommt an
dem auto hast du wärst profi da haben
zwei blöcke gefehlt oder so dass wir das
für betroffene eine außerdem hast du
geworfen du hast du
jetzt erstmals der typ kommt
max a
gute combo aber okay wir gehen jetzt zu
sein welche ging es zu sein wenn wir
können gehen wir zu seinen wert
probieren müssen unser wetter zu
bestellen schon direkt wieder was nicht
passt wird er heute ist mein kind unter
tv-spot killen was heißt dass wir fallen
runter und wenn wir wieder respawn tötet
dann schon was ein und fördert
renn renn renn renn renn wie soll ich
rennen bedeuten würde abgeordnet wurde
abgebaut wir gehen jetzt zu sein wir
müssen jetzt perfekt laufen luca keine
fehler ein paar sekunden später
kommt
egal jungwirth wäre richtig gut gespielt
wird zu zweit das war es echt gut ich
finde wir haben trotzdem gut gemachter
richtig gut wenn man sich das letzte mal
anschaut
beim letzten mal was halt so dass wir
dauerhaft ihnen herunter gefallen sind
als in der mitte waren und kommt nämlich
gar nicht kämpfen diesmal mit zwei
betten abgebaut da durch die zwei leute
getötet und wir hätten wenn die ender
perle gut angekommen wäre hätten wir
locker auch noch gewonnen wenn euch das
video gefallen meine damen und herren
freuen wir uns über eine bewertung max
kann also eine beschreibung verlinkt
werden